[Nobunaga] Power armor mechs
were the Mongols' advantage.
It's how they conquered
the Japanese settlements
of Tsushima and Iki Islands.
After we defeated them,
we took this technological advancement
for ourselves to strengthen our borders.
-[deep, rhythmic drumbeats]
-The ancestors say knowledge is power.
I respectfully disagree.
Power is power.
[grunting]
[Nobunaga] A simple concept
my son cannot seem to grasp.
Nobukatsu's defeat to Hattori Hanzo
will be told for generations to come.
A mark my legacy cannot afford.
[panting]
[both grunting]
[slow applause]
[man] My lord,
what brings you to the training grounds?
[Nobunaga] Our upcoming
parley with the Iga general.
Yasuke and Natsumaru will accompany you.
If I may, that would be a mistake.
I fear the rest of society
will not accept the… [hesitates]
…liberties you've taken with our culture.
Yasuke has proven to have
a fine military mind in his own right.
As good as you, perhaps even better.
How can we ever progress
when our instinct is to recede?
I want the Iga Clan to see a glimpse
of how bright our country's future can be.
[Mitsuhide scoffs]
My lord, if you continue
to add these outsiders to our ranks,
your enemies will neither fear
nor respect us.
Yasuke is not one of us.
Our people will not accept him.
I will soon represent the people,
and I will usher them into a new world.
[scoffs]
He really does not like me.
Give Mitsuhide time.
Nobunaga puts faith in you
he does not show in others.
That can rub some the wrong way.
[chuckles] And how does it rub you?
Nobunaga believes in theOnna Bugeisha.
So, you and I are alike.
Huh.
It's nothing.
The seal from my family crest,
given to me by my mother
and her mother before her.
It's honorable.
The past informs our future.
It shows who we are.